معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد الياس
نبدا بتطورات باخموت وسعي فاجنر
لتسليم المناطق التي تخضع للسيطرتها
للقوات الشيشانيه في حال ما اذا تم ذلك ما
الذي يعني على ارض الواقع
وسيله الحديث عن الانسحاب والتسليم هو هين
ان يقال ولكن في التنفيذ هذا امر يعتبر من
العمليات العسكريه حتى عندما قرر بريكوجين
الانسحاب او هدد بالانسحاب هي بحد ذاتها
عمليه عسكريه يعني معركه فقط العشره اشهر
ان يذهب الجندي الذي قاتل في هذه المعركه
وان يؤتى بشيء جديد وعي المكان والزمان
يستلزم وقت
ويؤدي الى خسارات كبيره هذا الامر ليس
بالامر السهل وليس بالامر البسيط يبدو
وسيله ان القرار الروسي العسكري هو
الانتقال من مرحله الهجوم حيث هناك من
هجوم مثل وكريمينا ولمان الى موقع الدفاع
تحسبا للهجوم المرتقب من القوات
الاوكرانيه
فيما يتعلق بتطور الاخر وهو اسقاط
صاروخ كنجال فرط صوتي ما الذي يعني ذلك ما
اهميته بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني
اولا وسيله الكنجال هو احد اهم الاسلحه من
سته منظومات تعتبر من الجيل الجديد تباها
به الرئيس بوتين بالعام 2018 على انه يمكن
له خرق الدفاعات الجويه الامريكيه لاول
مره
يعني يلتقي الكنجال مع الباتريوت واذا
صدقت المعلومات بعد يعني التدقيق بما تبقى
من الصاروخ يبدو ان الامر هي الغلبه
للباتريوت وهذا امر سيؤدي الى التطورات
مختلفه خلال الحرب حتى الان 50 صاروخ
فنجان اطلق على اوكرانيا فاذا السؤال
دائما وسيله ما هي اهميه الفرد صوتي ما هي
الاضافه النوعيه في المعركه اذا يمكن
اسقاطه بالباتريوت ويجب ان نعترف كمان
ايضا وسيله ان الساحه الاوكرانيه ساحه
التجربه لكل الاسلحه هذا شيء جديد وتطور
مختلف تطور مختلف برايي كيف ستتعامل مع
روسيا
يعني اليوم اذا الكنجال لم يعد ينفع يجب
ان نسال وسيله بعد يومين من المسيرات فوق
الكرملين الكنجال فوق كياف فما هو الهدف
الاساسي اليوم هناك بطاريتين من الباتريوت
واحده من المانيا واحده من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كل بطاريه لديها 8
قاذفات كل قاذفه اربع صواريخ عند تتحدث عن
ما يقارب ال 864 صاروخ فاذا هناك حمايه
للمراكز الصقل الاساسيه وهذا الامر قد
يحمي القيادات السياسيه القيادات العسكريه
في ظل التهديد الروسي بضرب واغتيال
الشخصيات هذا الامر سيؤثر فعلا على
المرحله القادمه او العمليه العسكريه اذا
حصلت في الوقت القريب شكرا جزيلا لك عميد
الياس حنا ضيفنا من بيروت وانت الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي